fives Joe Vasquez reports police are
trying to piece together what happened
oh gee the video posted on Twitter and
Instagram shows a small crowd
surrounding an older man who appears
have been collecting cans the language
ISM then at times
bystanders chimed in it's not clear
whether the man was hurt or anything was
stolen but what is clear is one man does
take a swing and as the victim bursts
into tears
others mock him I don't have the full
video so I can't know what happened but
I'm not shocked I'm disappointed that
this happened the way it happened but
I'm in no way shape or form surprise of
it I've seen things like that from
everybody name a group of people I've
seen things like that hat I've seen
people of guilty of that behavior in all
the groups but they're saying it's just
black people I'm not saying that it's
just black people that are like that no
that's all I'm saying I'm just pointing
out there that I'm not surprised of what
happened there because I've seen that in
like in all the groups for different
reasons like minorities don't like each
other hmm
it's not it's not just you know isms is
not just a black and white thing
I mean brothers like what the older
context is I'm like you just you don't
hit old people it's just that simple to
me you don't there's clearly an elderly
man you don't for me the buck stops
there it doesn't get more complicated
than that when I see some guys swing of
weapon at an old man with a plastic bag
I'm like that's a note for me like in my
country even if like an old person
tapped you behind them head it's like a
community thing beside you messing up
and they might do something but you
don't hit like if you were to beat up an
old person in my country you get messed
up you don't do that I really don't see
myself in Haiti ating old person would
die and then the second thing is just
like the fact that people were all
around filming it it's just I don't
understand that part of our culture this
is the one thing I do not get if you're
gonna engage in criminal activity
activity don't be stupid enough to post
it there's whole world star hiphop call
your thing is just dumb to me okay stop
there's a fight that breaks out people
why they cellphone is dumb
stop doing that y'all forgetting to be
humans just so you can get a couple
human likes this is dumb mmm y'all were
more concerned with documenting than
stopping it protecting it let's say it
was your friend swinging stop them from
swinging and if it's not your friend
stop insulting somebody I don't know
what to tell you you guys are just don't
get it if you're watching this and
you're one of those people just stop
just put your phone down nobody cares if
you got the video nobody cares nobody
cares that's really excitement that you
get from getting the scoop nobody's
gonna remember before for me these are
like character defining moments when you
see something like this happening in
front of you you do nothing that's a
problem I wouldn't want to associate
with you that's me though on the third
point
this'll presupposes the ability to
control a significant segment of the
population economically politically and
socially by imposing law covenant and
restriction on their lives black people
ain't had no capacity to do that can we
be bigoted yes can we be prejudiced yes
no that's always a weird like with the
talk about systems and stuff like that
as if black folks only exists in the
North American context go to Rwanda and
go tell the the titties that there's no
right good luck no no what you guys are
doing is were being prejudicial as you
wiped out the other tribe what listen
that's just a new-age definition that
came out of sociology departments and
universities just did to really paint
black people as always the victim and
white people is always the perpetrator
the reality is just like you guys talk
about indian ism there's such a thing as
intersectionality yes yes nothing is
just everyone's on this level and
everyone else on this level no your
income level changes things your
strength level changes things they might
be really poor they might be born with a
disease we don't know and so it's never
black and white there's not because
you've been bullied that you cannot
believe if you understand that concept
and you can't come into this and you
like black people cannot be what is the
point of saying that if something is
clearly wrong right and we all agree is
clearly wrong and so in this instance we
see something but yeah but this is not
systemic okay get that system
stuff out of here sometimes it can
happen on a micro-level sending y'all
like microaggressions right right I like
the little stuff are you talking yeah I
like the little stuff great all right oh
you talk about a lift I'm just talking
to people who love saying that kind of
stuff so don't take away from real
conversations just so you can be like
yeah but black people can't be as bad
it's a useless stop something terrible
happened
someone was dealt with in justly and
that we should fight for that sense of
justice for them they said what we want
justice for ourselves and less thing we
want to do is leave a comment about like
I know I'm gonna see people makan be
like this world just needs to end things
are getting so bad calm down listen if
you think things are bad now you just be
grateful that we didn't have cellphones
in the 90s and the 80s if they were
filming that boo-boo broth you would be
seeing some most gory stuff you'd ever
seen in your life and crime has dropped
drastically since that it's much safer
today than it was imagine this before
you only here used to hear about bad
stuff in your city now you hear about
bad stuff all over the world and it
seems like everything around you is
really bad but if you walk outside if
you walk through your city for the most
part is you want to be mostly safe I'd
aren t you freak up the stats or the
last 20 years it is far more safe than
it used to be so don't let this kind of
stuff cloud your vision of the future
don't let this kind of stuff dampen your
optimism because the reality is
empirically things are much better than
they've ever been
it's just that it's documented more
that's it you hear about a mudslide in
China and you're just like oh my god so
many people the world is like mudslides
and things like that we're always
happening it just didn't end up in your
news 30 years ago that's it and most
people didn't care about stuff happening
outside their community when I was
growing up I didn't know what Hong Kong
was Hong Kong to me it was just food you
ate off a plate when I was a kid my
neighborhood was the only thing that
matters affair and a couple TV shows
there yeah that makes perfect sense
what matters is just surrounding when
you're yeah yeah you know so now you you
wake up now and now you wake up and
everyone's like Oh in Bangkok said I was
like oh that just sounds like soy sauce
I put on my food so when I was growing
up that was my perception of the world
mmm all this to say those were the kind
of the points I had don't touch the
elderly stop
documenting this stuff stop what the
hole is it's not isms it's this it's a
useless conversation I have instances
like these let people feel some type of
way about this stuff and then the last
thing I would say is don't let this make
your world seem like the worst because
it's not it's just it's just not so
that's pretty much all I know leave your
comments below
[Music]